[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i'm gonna start with nice sent you home
because you lost that
i was working the door
so i was working the door at the store
at store and andrew does clay walks up
to me i don't even know him
and he goes hey ching get in the car
he used to call me ching
right he didn't know my name for 10
years
every time chiang
and i go my name is bobby no you're
ching i go that's racist he goes no as
chi-ching you got your money
right he tried to switch it up
he flies me first-class i have my
cognizawa t-shirt on first class to las
vegas
right and he goes you're going to be my
good luck charm
he loses
750 thousand dollars
how long
in in 24 hours it would i'd never see i
mean imagine having no money and then
but what was [ __ ] up about it is the
whole ride over there he was like you're
going to get 10 of my winnings
so in my head is if he makes a million
dollars
i'm gonna make a hundred grand
right but now he's down 7.50
right and he goes go home i went home
and he didn't talk to me for a year
before my daughter was born i met a
woman at flappers one night just very
casually in the back she was like uh
she did something for flappers and i
didn't and i
i'm no [ __ ] man
come on you looking great what am i
going to do with a girl
oh man i got 55 year old nuts they look
like they're 55.
for a young girl to suck them i wouldn't
get no satisfaction on it i'm just
[ __ ] somebody's world up yeah
i'm just [ __ ] somebody's world right
yeah it's like one time rogan asked me
he goes did you ever have a girlfriend
that committed suicide no but if anybody
sucked my dick i'd kill myself
yeah i killed myself yeah yeah it's
disgusting yeah understand me it's just
disgusting like we've gone through
comedy hell
like it's disgusting and you know i
think an indian chick in boise idaho one
time on the dance floor i was fingering
and she had a yeast infection how could
you know i took my hand out and it was
covered in yogurt how the [ __ ] does that
happen
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean how
the [ __ ] did
like you know i do i have a bit about
like a thai hooker eating my butthole
right and then my girlfriend was like
yeah my mom was in the audience and i
just don't think you should have told
that joke i go what's wrong with it like
i don't know that it's wrong but i guess
well is it wrong it's it's not wrong
it's just that they don't
they're offended by it or that it makes
them weird you have to understand when a
midwestern white person or whatever
right they go to
they they have church on sundays right
they go to work from nine to five you
know i mean they have kids they don't
know anything about that so when i'm
bent over on a stool
and this asian lady's eating my butthole
right like to me that's every day you
know what i mean i think about that
every day yeah that's my life it's
lifestyle you know what i mean but to
them it's like oh
mush with the bill the whole thing nice
yeah he's getting really lazy with his
edibles you know nice those wrappers
already open when i get it yeah but i
did that for a reason
he doesn't know what i did
listen what'd you do let me explain
something you just took everything
every day the mexican government ships
in a hundred kilos a day into the
a lot of cocaine
but they break it up they ship sixty
thirty
and then three intense
sixteen thirty
60 30 and then 333 yeah they six they
said 60
and then they send like uh four tens
so 10 kilos on one meal 10 kilos on the
other
10 kilos in the one meal and the grand
prize is the 60 they they work with
statistics and percentages
all right so they get
one of those meals get busted
they lose 10 kilos but they still get in
90.
so it doesn't matter they they they
include that in the prophet
so today
i gave away a [ __ ] every day
when i have an edible you see these
edibles here yeah they come in a little
butter packet so what i do is i open
them and i pop them and i pop him for a
purpose
because he thinks there's something in
him
and i constantly [ __ ] with him and i
[ __ ] with him because he lets me
so if you open that up look inside of
that there's a little butter back here
yeah why didn't i let you this i have a
choice i tell them listen
i open them and then i put them in there
and reseal them
really i don't do nothing to them so
today
last night i got them with the spray
bottles
well i sprayed the [ __ ] i sprayed
this
oh yeah you get [ __ ] up you really do
yeah so tonight i sprayed the
deactivizer
and i hit a xanax a little quarter xanax
in the bottom it was upside down caught
the xanax he thought he was like an
inspector he thought he was like an mba
inspector
but next you know he swallowed the
[ __ ] cat tranquilizer
so who gives a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
i don't know these kids that get these
things that's fine i'm happy for
everyone that gets it okay but there are
just certain people right that it's just
a given
all right
you did
25 years of time
into this thing
all right and you were always in it you
were never like some of these guys yeah
i i went away for 10 years i came back
you know this guy was like me we were in
the pocket when do i always see you why
because it's not because i mean i like
seeing you but it's because you and i
have never quit we never quit yeah we're
always just oh there he is he's just a
part of
my reality because him and they're both
guys that refuse to leave the game we've
got nowhere to go we're like richard
george i have places to go dude i don't
know where to go i can go to mountain
tops i can go to beach cities i can go
all over the world you would have
somewhere to go you would have gone
already no but here who puts up with
this [ __ ] abuse
who puts up with this people choosing us
netflix not giving you a special but
you're following paul mooney for a year
who the [ __ ] are they to decide that's
why we're so lucky you and i have tried
that no other kind of passion
are you ready for this yeah you know
what you and i are what
are you have the air force
you have the army you have the [ __ ]
marine maybe see him you have my navy
seal we are the navy seals
[ __ ] gets danged danger
again
so who the [ __ ] is anybody
to judge me is there a picture of me an
improv not really
there's not a pic you don't see me on
any shows getting interviewed by conan
you know
i'm saying yeah yeah
i go to facebook right or my instagram
whatever social media and i'll scroll
through like you know these younger guys
on conan and all these jimmy kimmel all
these things
now go correct that's great and then
always in my back of my head is like
i've never even been invited
yeah i'll never go
i'm on a show now right
a network show they have that up front
every year
two year two upfronts they've had so far
right
two yeah
do they invite bobby no they have never
been there
and all they talk about is diversity and
yeah i mean i'm on the show which is
great yeah that's good and that was
great but you know it's like for laughs
just for laughs
never been no me neither oh no
now they know yeah but they you've never
been to
montreal never never even they said they
didn't like the twitch i did with my
hand when you
that's an actual note i'm gonna tell you
something that happened to me in austin
and i can't even believe you just said
that because and it's the mo it's an
atrocity right and i'm gonna sue i might
sue
i was playing austin a year ago okay on
the books
matt blake calls me he goes you're out
of your
week a weekend right you're out of
boston
i go why
because rich miller called me and said
that the year before
you were in a limo
with the limo driver you pulled your
dick out and you told the limo driver to
suck your dick
that's what he said did you no what what
the [ __ ]
no i didn't do that right
i go excuse me matt first of all when
have i ever been in a [ __ ] limo
and number two nick youssef my opener
was with me every second of every day i
never [ __ ] did that why would i do
that i'm sober right i go give me rich
miller's number rich miller is dennis
miller's brother
they don't know that people are
listening right so rich miller is dennis
miller's brother and he books comedy
rooms right and he lives in minnesota
i don't know the [ __ ] guy right i
call rich miller
he answers i go dude
i never pulled my dick out
and told some white limiter to suck my
dick i'm not gay and also i'm sober like
i'm in the aaa i have a sponsor you know
me i pray i meditate why the [ __ ] would
i do that he goes i don't know anything
about that
i double booked you
right i double booked you and it's the
other guy's a friend of mine he has no
money but i'll get you back on the books
that's what the [ __ ] guy tells me
right
i hang up the phone i call matt i go
that's what rich said
he didn't even mention the dick sucking
thing right so the matt called it rich
again
matt calls me back yeah
you did it
the dick sucking
so the rich miller can't say it to my
face
he lies to me on my face right and then
tells my agent that i did it
i never did it and then i had my manager
and my lawyer call the club itself to
bypass rich they won't answer our phone
calls i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened there i love that [ __ ] room
that's a great room i know it is
i know it's a great room but i never why
would i why would i tell a stranger a
guy to suck my dick
i know
i just okay listen listen to me right
now okay okay
ask me if i've ever sucked a dick before
have you sucked a dick yes whoa
i have
when in high school
why
because i was drunk i'm not gonna tell
you who it was with a bunny
he pulled his dick out
and i was now we're not high school i
was like maybe eighth to ninth grade
okay
eight to ninth grade okay okay did he
finish no no i just tasted a couple
times i didn't like it was salty right
so check it out
so i sucked it all right
i'm willing to admit
every [ __ ] awful dirty thing i've
ever [ __ ] done i'm not
i'm not a [ __ ] angel
i've made mistakes i've been in and out
of sobriety i've relapsed before
i know my failures and i know exactly
what i've done in my [ __ ] life all
right
if you've asked you know when they say
were you molested by a guy with down
syndrome yes
he stuck his little sweaty fingers in my
butthole when i was nine
and he gave me candy and i went back
every [ __ ] day for three summers in a
row to get that candy
and i let him stick his [ __ ] sweaty
fingers in my butthole and i jerk them
off i don't give a [ __ ] i want the
[ __ ] dip candy you know he had the
dip you know with the stick right right
so i went back
hear me every day for three summers road
to get my
candy what was it going on during the
school year what you what why why do you
want to go to bed because he was the guy
that mowed the lawn at the [ __ ]
skating rink during the summer and then
during the winter it was so he never
lived there but in the summer he was
like the groundsman right so it was only
in the summer and he lived in the shack
there right and he had this candy on the
rafters i'm just telling you this right
now because of the fact that it's a dark
thing
but it's like i'm i'll admit to it all
right
you know i've i've told my parents every
dirty thing i've ever [ __ ] done and
i've done many all right and i've
apologized for bad things
but i never pulled my dick out to a limo
driver until it's like my dick that
never [ __ ] happened i mean i didn't
know he was puerto rican whatever you
know what i mean or cuban whatever you
are yeah whatever yeah you know man
you've called me chinese before no i
haven't i always know you're korean oh
you
listen you could you're gonna expect
people to get upset especially in
today's society especially in the
society we live in
people gonna get accepts but what i
don't understand is it's like a movie
trailer before you go to the movie you
know there's some [ __ ] in the movie
or there's not you know it's pg or r
same thing with the club same thing with
youtube you could just go on youtube and
look at the comic oh i recognize him
from mad tv or from some [ __ ] movie
or whatever you know yeah but my thing
is is that i have a door deal
i don't give a [ __ ] if they left but
they get their money back right i'm
asian i want my money you want your
money yeah that was like that's like 22
dollars or whatever 25 bucks even if
they just thought three minutes [ __ ]
them [ __ ] your mother yeah yeah [ __ ] you
i want my [ __ ] 25 bucks
i'm from the oh
listen if they want to leave leave you
want your money back take the [ __ ]
money back you made a mistake if you but
most of these people in today's society
they go home write a review on yelp
send you a [ __ ] email tell you how i
had a guy that sent me a thing from
vegas because that was the [ __ ]
dirtiest show i've ever seen
learned something from cosby oh is that
what that's what he wrote to me i'm like
cosby rape [ __ ] women you dirty dumb
[ __ ]
so you know that's the you know
it just listen you're not gonna please
everybody
all the [ __ ] time somebody's gonna
get upset i feel bad when dead squad
guys come to my shows and bring their
wives
and they're like we love it you could
see the girls are like i don't even know
why i [ __ ] came here
this is crazy he's talking about eating
my ass and breaking into somebody's
house yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a
just the wrong way
[Music]